i have a question for all of you which
is
where are we have a look up on the map
took this screenshot um not that long
ago
and i love that actually this is updated
for a little while
google maps had some pretty old
satellite photography so for example
you couldn't see um your beautiful
jblock on there
i'll get it that's right
good morning come and grab the door
please
uh and it looks pretty good from the air
right i mean it looks good from the
ground too but
my question to you is where are we now
um that's not a rhetorical question um
we can actually we know where we are
right now situated right
i wonder if you've got a good enough
sense of spatial awareness to know
i mean i've put um some coordinates
across the top and along the side
where would you describe us now
what would you say it's a bit tricky i
haven't given the finest scale but
that's because i just didn't want to
cover this with
grid lines everywhere
five round five five is not a bad oh
yeah it's
someone gonna be somewhere between four
and five might be closer to four
actually because we're right on this end
of the building yeah i should say that
end of the building right
um and then in terms of letters
yeah between between g and h
aren't we g and a half whatever that is
okay
so what you're using right now of course
is
a coordinate system that requires a
horizontal
coordinate which is the letters and a
vertical coordinate which
is the numbers um can you tell i used to
play chess when i was a little kid now
we're used to understanding this kind of
coordinate system
roughly speaking this is what we use on
the cartesian plane right and therefore
we've kind of borrowed that idea moving
into what we're looking at now which is
not the cartesian
plane it's the argument it's the
we call them argan diagrams when you've
got complex numbers on there but broadly
speaking they're called it's called the
complex plane right same idea
so this is a way of describing where you
are any complex number you can think of
if you provide a horizontal coordinate
and a vertical coordinates like bam
that's where i am i can know precisely
but i wonder if you noticed and it's
even on
this screenshot itself this is not the
only way that we can describe
our position not worrying about
precision that kind of thing there's a
whole different way
to actually describe where you are that
has nothing to do
with horizontal or vertical
and i admit it's um it's kind of stuck
down in the corner and it's very small
so if you had my eyesight and you're in
the background you would not be able to
see it but
let me zoom in and help you out
down here do you notice there's another
pair of coordinates but they're not
horizontal or vertical
coordinates what are these numbers what
do they signify
this is longitude and latitude right now
when you look closely at longitudinal
attitude been a while since many of you
have thought about this to go back to
like
year 7 and 8 geography that kind of
thing or earlier actually
latitude and longitude as you can see by
the units themselves right
they're not about like meters kilometers
that kind of thing what
units are they in degrees
and minutes and seconds right
um by the way does anyone know why
they're called minutes minutes like
degrees are like you know degrees of
separation why are they called minutes
yeah go ahead okay there are 60th each
of a degree in other words
they're a minute portion of a degree
right when a degree is not sufficiently
small does anyone know why
degrees are in their minutes and then
they're called seconds and i know
they're called seconds
it's because it's the second minute
division when a minute is not enough
so you can see there are the markings
there now degrees minutes seconds what
are they
they are not measures of of distance
they're measures of
angle of rotation right now the reason
why and at this point i'm going to ask
you
good morning grab a seat at this point
i'm going to ask you to pick up your
pen slash pencil i haven't told you what
the heading is yet we'll come to that in
a minute
and i'd love you to do your very best to
draw something like what i'm about to
show you
the reason why we can have a coordinate
system
that's not just horizontal vertical but
can also be in terms of rotation
and angle is because we live
on a globe we live on something that's
roughly spherical it's of course
not exactly spherical but it's close
enough for our purposes
and we have these things sorry called
poles right we've got a north pole
and a south pole and we use that as our
reference point right
now if we say okay if i think about say
from the north pole right
if we look at the earth from the point
of view
of the north pole uh this is what you
look
at right this is what you see and
because the earth is
round we can think about for example
from
one of these lines going around does
anyone know what they're called by the
way apart from lines of longitude
there's a special name starts with an m
it's a pretty old fashion yeah they're
called meridians right very good
not a common word so don't worry about
if you don't know it we can take these
meridians and describe them as
angles around a point right you just
need to pick
one of the meridians to be like your
main one and then you measure from there
right now if i'm eyeballing this
correctly the main one oops let's uh
i'll stay with this car
the main one is around oh i remember
looking this up it's around here
this particular meridian doesn't go um i
can't show it all the way because this
only has the
northern uh the very very northern part
of the earth
um this one's going to go through a very
special place in the uk does anyone know
where it goes through it goes through
greenwich right
so um you know you can think about
greenwich mean time being
measured from here yeah yeah it looks a
bit it looks like a french for another
fun say it again sorry by the looks of
it it looks like a french one
oh you're talking about the map you mean
or that particular line
yeah i might have it might have been
this one that i wanted to pick so i'm
just in a vague ballpark right
um yeah i know yeah i think that's the
uk there yeah
yeah right yeah you're right i think
it's one yeah so maybe the one over to
the next
so the idea here is though whichever one
you choose it really is actually
arbitrary right
you pick a meridian this one is the
primer indian whichever one it is
and then you can see if i want to get to
anywhere describe a place
anywhere on this surface i can then just
rotate around a particular angle and
that's that's the angles that you saw at
the bottom
of this map over here and then i can
also rotate in this other direction
around the earth and that some latitude
not longitude right
so because this is based on poles right
you need a north pole you need a south
pole
we call these not cartesian right like x
and y
coordinates we call these polar
coordinates because they're based on
poles right so that's the heading i
would like you to make
polar coordinates this is a way that if
we can describe the earth like this
well we can describe anything in in two
dimensions like this
as well so let's come to the world that
we're more familiar with or we've been
working with over the last
little while right let's see primary
color here we go
so if i have some arbitrary complex
number
right um so far we have been labeling
these complex numbers as
a plus ib there's a real component
there's an imaginary component but to
sort of strengthen this connection with
the
with the cartesian plane which is so
much like this we want to take advantage
of all the intuition you've developed
over the course of many years about the
cartesian plane
we also will equally you'll see this
just as frequently as a
plus ib we sometimes describe these
complex numbers as
x plus i y
because the x being the real component
tells you where you are horizontally
and the y being the imaginary component
tells you where you are vertically
okay so you've got your x and you've got
your y
now how do i take advantage of this
polar idea
right well to get there in terms of
these
horizontal vertical components i just go
x
and then y but a polar coordinate needs
a
direction an angle to rotate to right i
want something
that takes me to this point
z now just like with the earth
in some senses we could measure from
anywhere we could have put the prime
meridian
anywhere that we liked in fact
throughout history people have put
their prime meridian in lots of
different places because surprise
surprise
everyone draws their map with their own
location at the center at least that's
where we started right
so that's arbitrary but for some really
good reasons i'm going to ask you for
one in a second
we have chosen the positive side
of the real axis the positive side of
the real axis
we've chosen that as our prime meridian
where we start measuring from
would anyone like to give me some
suggestions why that might be a good
place to define from
any takers
because it i mean it could have been
here we measure north from here
right and then true bearings go around
this way we referred to that last week
can you take us why does this make sense
as a place to start
think back to our first lesson as a
class together
where did numbers begin again what kinds
of numbers did we start with
we started with before way before real
numbers we started with
counting numbers right so the counting
numbers would be like you know
1 and then 2 and then 3 and so on and
then we started to fill in the numbers
between the counting numbers so we would
say oh you've got all the the fractions
and then after that we started thinking
about integers so that's this negative
side over here
so for a long time you know this this
part
of the complex plane that's the only
part we really knew about
in fact you've pretty much been doing
maths in that part and and in this part
for
like years and years and years right
it's a good place to actually use
as our reference point so therefore what
we say is let's measure up
an angle from the positive side
of the real axis let's call that theta
okay
now unlike our unlike our globe which
has two poles a north
and a south our complex plane really
kind of only has
one pole and that is right there in the
center it's the origin where the axes
meet
okay so as a consequence rather than
using a second
angle of rotation i've got one there's
theta measured from the positive
real axis to get to zed
after you know which direction you're
facing in you just have to know
how far along to go that distance in
there
okay now for reasons it'll become clear
a little bit later on
i'm going to call that r right so if we
know
r and we know theta
then just like if we knew x and y we can
know exactly where
z should be does this make sense